[Music]
So, going to talk about China, US,
Middle East, um, and then US
infrastructure. Um, and then a bit of a
Q&A if we have time. I don't know. I yap
a lot, so it's going to be hard. Um, so
20 minutes. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I got 20. I
got 20. That's plenty. Um,
time's ticking. Time's ticking. Should I
just Should I just stall so I don't have
Q&A? Crowd's tough. Um, so so I wanted
to talk about like Huawei's chips,
right? Cuz we don't ever get to talk
about them. Uh, there Huawei is is
really really cracked. Um, they
absolutely destroyed everyone in 5G and
telecom um by just engineering better.
Um, and now they've done something
that's that's super interesting. Um, so
they have the Ascend 910B and C, which
you may have heard of, which are chips
that they make. Um, and then they've
turned it into this like really cool
system architecture, right? Uh, you
know, Nvidia talks a lot about Blackwell
NVL 72. It's one rack with 72 GPUs. Um,
connected together in NVLink. Um,
Huawei's done something similar. It's
called the Cloud Matrix 384. 384 of
their chips, right? Connected together
in not one rack, but like 12. Um, and
there's a ton of optics and power
connecting them all. What's interesting
is that their architecture is actually
one that Nvidia tried to deploy and they
failed at um, and that was called uh,
DGX H100 Ranger, right? Which was 256
Nvidia GPUs connected together in one
NVLink network uh, with optics. Um, they
they tried and it did not work. They
could not bring it to production because
it was expensive, power hungry and
unreliable. Um and and that sort of was
the impetus for why Blackwell they
instead stopped going you know hey 1020
kilowatts per server to 120 kilowatts in
one server that is effectively one whole
rack because they wanted to keep it all
in copper right whereas DGX H100 Ranger
and also the Huawei system uses optics
to connect all the GPUs at super high
bandwidth in the high bandwidth you know
NVLink or uh I can't remember what the
Ascend cloud matrix pod is called their
scaleup network but it's quite
interesting that Huawei was able to
engineer something that Nvidia
effectively failed at. Right? Um now
obviously this this is um way more you
know power hungry of course um
potentially unreliable. There's no data
um and it would be expensive except for
the fact that like you know China's
really good at making things cheap,
right? So that's that's something
interesting about the Huawei system. Um
what's interesting about the geopolitics
of this is that despite the fact that
Huawei is a sanctioned entity, China is
a sanctioned country, they're still a
they were still able to actually access
uh TSMC to manufacture these chips,
right? Um the the chip is manufactured
through uh at TSMC through Sofco uh
which is a Bitcoin cryptocurrency mining
company uh that pretended to not be
attached to Huawei and just bought these
chips. Um, and then there's, you know,
HBM, which is high bandwidth memory from
Samsung and Highex in Korea. Um, and
then all the equip all the equipment to
package it together is from the US,
Netherlands, and Japan. So, it's funny
that sanctions are completely useless
because they're still able to access
this stuff. Um, and what's interesting
is, you know, what I'm showing on the
right is that they can they've made, you
know, they have roughly 3 million chips
worth 2.9 million chips worth uh from
TSMC. That's allegedly stopped now,
right? the US gave TSMC like a billion
dollar fine uh for $500 million of
revenue that they made uh which which
doesn't seems like a slap on the wrist
honestly. Um but you know Smick is also
going to which is China's TSMC is going
to start making it as well. Um, the
other thing I would say is what's funny
is that HBM was also banned to China
entirely, but instead of just like, hey,
HBM's banned, there's there's cool ways
to circumvent this, right? Which is uh
Samsung sells to this company called
Coasia in Taiwan and then Coasia sells
to this company called Faraday which
packages it into a chip. Like there's a
fake chip basically, right? A chip that
does literally nothing and it has HBM
packaged on it and they ship it to China
and then they take the HBM off of that
chip and then put it on the ascend. Um,
and this actually circumvents all the
rules and regulations. So, this is
completely legal. Um, which I think is
like very funny. Um, and so Huawei has
stackpiled roughly 13 million HBM
stacks. Um, you know, already. Um, and
they're continuing to receive more
shipments. Uh, which is fun. Uh, very
very interesting that, you know, that's
kind of possible. The other thing is,
um, you know, domestically they have not
been able to manufacture in the past,
but now they're able to, right? Um,
China's uh, Smick, right, their TSMC uh,
has enough tools for 50,000 wafers a
month. Today, the only 7nmter chip that
anyone's found from SMIC is their
smartphone chip, right? Smartphone chips
are smaller, easier to make. Um, they
yield better than large AI chips. Um, so
when you look at like, hey, 5nanmter,
the first 5nimeter chip was an iPhone
chip in 2020, but Nvidia didn't release
a 5nanmter GPU until uh, 2022, 2023 with
the H100, right? Uh and so likewise,
right, Smick is making seven nanometer
for phones. Uh they're going to get to
the point where they can start making
seven nanometer for AI chips likely in
very high volumes this year. Um and
based on the yields, they can actually
get like you know millions and millions,
right? So it's it's uh you know the the
thought that China will not have
equivalent compute is like kind of
wrong. They will they will have a lot of
compute, right? Um which is which which
will be interesting, right? because uh
you know there's already like big
announcements from DeepSeek that they're
going to work and use use Huawei chips
uh to try and train their next
generation models. Um and so that
that'll be really interesting. Um the
other thing that's interesting is um you
know recently Nvidia got banned from
selling their H20. This is like a cut
down H100 or H200 to China. um they
wrote down $5 billion worth of inventory
and on the earnings call, Colette, the
CFO said, "If we didn't have export
restrictions, we would have sold $50
billion worth of GPUs to China this
year." Which I thought was like a very
interesting comment. Um but uh the ban
stopped about a million GPUs and um if
you Yeah, it's it's it's it's quite
interesting that like you know that
amount of compute was also blocked. Um,
I think the other sort of geopolitical
thing that everyone's talking about
besides China is the Middle East, right?
Um, so recently there was a deal in the
Middle East. Uh, you know, Trump went to
the Middle East. He didn't go to Israel.
He only went to Saudi and UAE, which I
thought was quite interesting. Um, you
know, not to get political, but you
know, that's that's interesting. Um,
no, no more no more. No more.
Um, so the the details of the deal are
quite uh are cool, right? So on the
right is a satellite photo of a data
center complex in the UAE uh that G42 is
making. Um and the deal is basically
that G42 can buy 500,000 GPUs a year. Um
and they get to keep 20% of them to do
whatever they want. The other 80% have
to go to uh US hyperscalers and cloud
companies and AI companies, right? And
so uh G42 is building a 5 gawatt data
center campus. The one photo pictured is
the first parts of a gigawatt data
center campus, right? Um that is that is
absolutely ridiculously big, right?
XAI's data center is like 200 megawatts,
right? Um you know, OpenAI and all these
other guys are 200 or less megawatts for
the models they've released. So these
are absolutely ginormous, right?
Stargate, the first uh first six parts
of it in total is 1.2 gigawatts, right?
So like this is a this is a massive um
data center that they're building. Um,
G42
has a large customer and investor,
Microsoft. And so, Microsoft is going to
be a big one. But if everyone remembers
back like in 2023, Sam was always like,
"Hey, 7 trillion, right? You know, he's
throwing this crazy ass number out or
everyone kept reporting about it." Um,
the interesting thing is that part of
this was that um, OpenAI wanted to build
GPU clusters in the Middle East, right?
Um, and so, uh, not not like publicly
stated, but it's like it's like open is
going to have a cluster in the Middle
East, right? Um, and so that's a big
part of this deal as well. Um, and and
in in concession, right, the US gets a
couple benefits, right? Uh, UAE is uh
providing matching investments to uh,
US, right? For any dollars they spend in
UAE, the UAE spends in UAE on AI
infrastructure, they're also going to
spend in the US. Um, and so that's
already started, right? G42 has sites in
like Kentucky and New York, um, that
they're spending in. Nothing that's 5
gigawatts, but I'm sure they'll they'll
get something. Uh, we'll see if this
like all follows through. Uh, the other
thing is that most of the compute goes
to uh, US companies, right? 80% of it.
Um, I think, you know, you could spin it
any way you want, right? Um, but the
lines are also blurring, right? um
people today now uh in their inference
clusters at night in the US are just
running reinforcement learning with
verifiable rewards generating you know
trajectories and then you know keeping
the good tokens uh when there's low
utilization right so like inference
clusters are now also training clusters
right so I think I think that there's
like the lines are blurring between what
is an inference and training cluster but
also this is a 5 gigawatt data center
like that's that's big um you could do
training for sure let's can we keep
questions sure yeah we can actually do
questions in this round but come up
afterwards. Sorry. Um, no worries. No
worries. Uh, the other one the other one
is uh I I think I think if we want to we
can yell questions, you know.
Um, the other one is uh the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia. Um, data vault is a
company there. Uh, if you've heard of
the line uh in Saudi Arabia, it's an
absolutely ridiculous project. It's
actually really cool. there's building a
city that's a straight up line and on
both sides they have like huge sets of
like mirrors so they don't have a ton of
sun like making the city way too hot and
it's clean and whatever right like it's
a really interesting thing there's a lot
of YouTube slop videos that you could
watch that show how cool it is um but
anyways part of that uh line project is
also data vault who is making a data
center and this is real this is
definitely happening they've already
struck uh broke ground on like a 2
gigawatt data center um and again like
for context XAI's entire training
infrastructure today is 200 megawatts,
right? Uh and they've spent like 10 plus
billion dollars on it, right? Like you
got to you got to rationalize these
numbers. Uh it's like 10x more, right?
Um so so data volt is going to invest
$20 billion in US data centers in
addition to building a bunch in um the
Middle East. Um
and then and then a bunch of American
companies are going to invest as well.
Uh so total investment number is like 80
billion dollars. Uh datavolt is the data
center company for humane which is uh
sort of the cl neoc cloud for the data
center company right um and so humane uh
they've signed deals to like get custom
CPUs from Qualcomm and buy a bunch of
AMD GPUs as well as Nvidia GPUs uh
Humane is actually the Ramco uh folks
the Ramco Ramco digital folks which is
the vast majority of Grock's revenue as
well so there's uh likely Grock stuff in
there um I think like 90 plus% of
Grock's revenue or or they've got fun
money from them is coming coming from uh
from from the Ramco digital folks. Um
likewise um you know and then there's
also an AWS thing, right? So there's all
all these American companies are also
like coming together with the Middle
East. So the question is like you know
why the heck are we sending all these
GPUs to the Middle East is what like the
EAS would say and then the like
capitalists will be like [__] yeah GPUs
and money, right? So like it depends on
what side of the fence you're on. Um,
and I like to think, you know, I'm uh
I'm on one side of the fence, so I'll
tell you which side.
You could guess. You could guess. Um,
so, you know, there there are real
criticisms, right? Like, what if these
GPUs get smuggled, right, to China? Um,
because it's not like Saudi Arabia and
the UAE are allies. Um, they are uh they
they conveniently play both sides,
right? Um, and and always have. So,
there's always that risk. there's all
these security requirements like okay
what if okay they're not maybe the GPUs
don't get smuggled there maybe they get
rented to China right um you know
there's argument that these GPUs would
have been used in the US anyways um and
so and and and we know that export
restrictions and things like that the
enforcement of them sucks so it's not
like the US government apparatus is
going to actually be able to effectively
enforce this right so there's there are
real risks here um and and also like
giving power to authoritarian countries
and that have like you kingdoms, right?
It's it's kingdom of Saudi Arabia. It's
princes, right? You know, it's a little
bit odd. Um, so so that's sort of the
arguments against it. Um, and then and
then the supporters are obviously,
right? Like yes, more GPUs. Most of
these GPUs go to American companies,
right? Like an easy example is OpenAI,
right? Uh they they they want a lot lot
more GPUs. Uh Microsoft OpenAI deal sort
of split up partially because OpenAI
wanted so many GPUs and Microsoft was
like, "No, you're crazy. Like that's way
too much. like you don't have revenue.
Um, and OpenAI is like but we can
convince someone to build it for us,
right? Because OpenAI is really nice,
right? Like they get to rent the GPUs.
Uh, and so like but the thing is their
provider has to build the data center
and buy all the GPUs and then they don't
get payback for two or three years,
right, of renting GPUs even though the
contract is for like five years. So
yeah, there's all this theoretical
profit, but you don't actually get the
money back on the cluster until year two
or three. So if Microsoft now builds a
hundred billion data center for OpenAI
and then OpenAI doesn't raise $150
billion to pay for it um then then you
know Microsoft is just left holding the
bag and who wants that big of a data
center right so unless you believe like
AI's demand is like unlimited then you
know you kind of there's a big risk here
and the nice thing is like you know a
fool is easily parted with their money
um and SoftBank and the Middle East are
the most stupid investors in the world
potentially
um and so you know I actually I think
they're fine I think They're fine. I
think these are good deals, but like you
know um you know OpenAI gets to have
someone pay for the cluster um buy all
these GPUs, build all the data centers
and then like with the promise they're
going to rent them, right? And the same
applies to all the other AI labs across
the uh west, right? Um and so the
argument that like I would make is that
you know OpenAI it because of this will
have more compute in 2027 or 2028 than
they would have had without it, right?
It wouldn't have been built in the US.
Also, there's big problems with America
in terms of being able to build GPUs,
right? Um, and that is that there is a
massive deficit of power, right? Um, so,
uh, there's no access on the chart on
the left for a reason, right, for people
taking a picture. Um, but on the right,
you know, Middle East is building, you
know, by 2030 like four gigawatts,
right? I said they promised five, but
like from what we see, they'll have like
four by 2030. Um the US has a humongous
humongous deficit on um power. Um I will
skip forward a bit. Um power China's
good at making power. US is not. Right.
This is an interesting one. Right. Um so
I presented to this to uh to the
secretary writen Bergman in February um
in in DC and it's a really interesting
chart, right? It's like so on the right
is like sort of our data center data,
right? saying there is a 63 gawatt uh
shortfall of power in the US right based
on the data centers that we see under
construction and we're tracking every
single one site by sight etc building by
building um with satellite photos
permits regular providings all this
stuff right and on the left is the US
power grid right um so you you can have
a lot of like strong assumptions about
renewables bio batteries um and then all
of the single cycle and dual cycle gas
reactors that are being installed and
then you say hey actually almost none of
the coal is going to turn off that is
planned to turn off and you still have
this massive mass you have 44 gigawatts
being added but you have a um on on the
power side um and that's that's assuming
you know with the fluctuations all that
right uh whereas you're adding 100
gawatts of data center capacity so the
US simply just doesn't have enough power
unless we do something and so the
argument sort of is like well
geopolitically the US can't build um
enough data centers can't build enough
power whether it's for the lack of
skilled labor whether it's for the lack
of you know regulatory regulators
holding stuff up. Um, federal, not as
much anymore, but local, state, and also
in America, we have this beautiful thing
called utility companies that are
regulated monopolies that get to do
whatever they want, right? If anyone has
a power bill in California, they
understand that the utilities [__]
suck. Um, anyways, um, there there's all
these issues with building power in the
US, right? And if we go back, China has
no problem, right? They added an entire
US grid in seven years, right? Um and so
and we're talking about adding, you
know, you see four terowatt hours on the
on the right graph. I'm talking about
adding a 100 gigawatts as a problem,
right? Um because the US just doesn't
know how to
or rather hasn't done it in in like four
decades. Um and so that's the big sort
of uh challenge. So for every Stargate
that's out there, right, um you know,
220 megawatts for these four building
like things and there's two of them
already almost completed and then
there's another six going up. Uh that's
1.2 2 gawatts total for Stargate. Um,
for every one of these that's happening,
there's so many projects that are
failing, right? Like I've literally
pitched a coal stock to my clients in
Ohio and the stocks 3x because there's
power issues. Like like it's it's crazy
how um how power constrained America is,
right? And so the geopolitics here is
like do you build in the Middle East or
not? Uh China's got no pro power
problems. Even if their chips are less
efficient, doesn't really matter, right?
Like I think the AI race is a very
geopolitical and interesting one. Um,
and so I'll sort of leave it there. I
know there's there's there's a couple
more slides, but yeah,
couple questions. Two minutes
[Applause]
dependent on
SMIC SMIC, China's TSMC is uh dependent
entirely on Western tools today. Uh, but
there are many uh Chinese tool
companies. So, what's interesting is
they'll buy billions of dollars of uh
American, Japanese, and Dutch equipment,
including ASML, but then they'll put it
next to their domestic tool, and then
they'll run uh wafers through both, and
then they'll just like learn how to
improve it. They'll also tear them down
and reverse engineer them. Um, yeah,
it's cool.